[Music]
put your toe the limit this Sochi our
pocket sushi sushi sushi all the way you
dumb [ __ ] can't do pokey too much and
Army Rangers hellish training is
apparently the blame for turning him
into a criminal what let's hear this
Thor code that has to be a little bit
alright so this story is about Alex
Bloom he's 30 years old yellow M or BL
um e BL um oh I thought it was beating
um ve o my guess is Blum right you don't
know Army private first class does that
mean anything I just like alluring
that sounds gay Cyril all right well
before the dishonorable charge his life
is over
sorry discharged I said charge so his
cousin Ben Blum is right he has written
a book about him called Ranger games a
story of soldiers family and an
inexplicable crimes really long it
describes Alex as a good kid with a
dream to serve his country of ending up
being criminal story begins back in 2005
after graduating high school he reported
to his basic training at Fort Benning in
Georgia after like five months of what
he described as hell is what really
broke him down is what he said so Alex
told his cousin Bendis quote the nonstop
continuous negative reinforcement erases
any and all self-confidence you once had
you firmly believe that you can't do
anything right you believe that you are
incompetent and unworthy of anything
elegant oh yeah so then after he did his
boot camp he returned for the Ranger
indoctrination program AKA r.i.p this
program is designed to weed out the weak
and only a small percentage actual
make it out to be a Rangers so the way
he describes his experiences he says
that privates were ordered to run a
quarter mile in freezing temperatures
while wearing only cotton fatigues to go
gather wood bundles while wearing heavy
packs and then they would repeat this
over and over only to stop and have to
crawl through fire ant infested pond how
to fire at swim and pause they get like
bags and just throw it in the pond so
people get these are at Rangers they
hold each other like and they make
little island and yeah during harvey
yeah so they're saying they couldn't
sleep for 24 hours and then when they
were finally able to sleep they'd be
woken up five minutes later and then go
through the quarter mile trek all over
again
they had to wear wet clothing for 24
hours and then when they were given dry
clothes they would be then ordered to
jump into a pond
five minutes later after getting the
dried clothes that's our core drill
sergeants were urinate in that pond and
the soldiers would still have to go
through it and they'd be vomiting but
they still have to carry out their
exercises covered in like the urine and
their vomit and he was saying that he
began to use Tabasco as eyedrops to stay
awake it was just so intense that's
unique and then he began hallucinating
and then he also told his cousin this
before I joined the army I was vibrant
funny easygoing loving and independent
when I got my tan beret I was a shell I
was an angry testosterone-driven
prick I was unable to value human life
wait so he got the Britta's in he passed
I really did I mean I think it's all
about expectations too because I'm not
in the military but I I know what I'm
getting myself into
if I sign up for things like this like I
don't know what people think when they
join these more specialized groups and
all that stuff unless it's like army
engineering maybe your sole purpose is
to kill that is your job so you're
supposed to be desensitized to murder
because you don't want it
guy that has a conscience when he's out
there and it's like you have to make
decisions there's a kid with the bomb
what do you do you know like you gotta
kill the kid right like that's just the
unfortunate reality of war I think it's
just a lot of them went into this
thinking they can handle it and just
they simply can't and they just break
few things since he was a really little
kid like it was a dream to like serve
his country and like he just saw it I
was like you know probably the
recruiters probably did a bad job of
explaining the expectations - because
army basic training isn't known to be
hard but the Ranger School is so if he's
already complaining about basic training
I think he's probably already not fit
for Ranger school because most people
don't get broken down and army basic
training so he was talking about boot
camp broke him down because that's when
he left basic he is already like all
that negative reinforcement happening
there and then we graduated I think he's
already disgruntled now when he sent him
to Ranger School that's when like the
stuff gets really hard which is supposed
to because it's like special operations
yeah like Rangers are people jumping out
of airplanes doing crazy [ __ ] like you
can't you're supposed to stay awake for
24 hours like he should not bother you
like fire ants should not bother like
that should just like some crazy [ __ ]
the sergeant's peeing upon what your
people once you're going to like the
special operations and stuff they do a
lot of crazy [ __ ] isn't it more like
from their perspective these drill
sergeants that are in Ranger school
there are also Rangers so what they're
trying to do is produce other people
that they can trust to watch their back
yeah because they're thinking if I'm
doing this special operation and I'm I'm
like let's say I'm training you I want
to make sure Gina I'm gonna put Gina
through hell so that I know I can trust
Gina in three months that she's gonna
watch my back the way I need it to be
washed
cuz think about it do you want a ranger
who pisses himself on accident and
that's not the problem the problem is
he's so uncomfortable from the urine
that he [ __ ] smells on himself that
he can't even focus on his duty yeah on
his job you know like the way that this
is written is like oh it was horrifying
I had to go through this and that and
it's like normal
you weren't incarcerated in a place
where you know it's like you signed up
you signed up to
to be a professional killer you signed
up to do that
and you signed up to be in a specialized
unit that that has to deal with
stressors that are beyond the average
you know could the way this is written
it's I feel like he's trying to gain
sympathy but for me because I revere
Army Rangers at such a high [ __ ]
caliber it's not me as a feeling saying
I don't want to hear that [ __ ] I'm
saying like yeah you're the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're supposed to go through [ __ ] like
that that's how I view Army Rangers like
special you know Nate everybody in that
caliber when I hear them go through that
I'm like you're not a normal human being
and that is the caliber of of military
excellence that you are that's the kind
of guy I want protecting our nation
because I was like I don't want a guy
that gets captured and then he breaks
under a little bit of pressure on
someone like he sees a fire and he tells
all the secrets I don't want someone
who's crawling through the trenches and
he gets bit by a fire ant and then he
goes whoo hold on I got a little out
sheet you know like I want I want tough
guys like that that can handle all of
that and also I want them to handle that
during a test area not when they're out
in the battlefield you know like you
want guys that are like hardened before
they go out there cuz it also sounds
like like because Army Rangers are
revered like it sounds like someone
going to Harvard and saying they had a
really hard time yeah well this is like
the best school in the nation you're
supposed to have a very hard time here I
feel like he's he's trying to demonize
them when really you're just not cut out
for that because there's thousands of
thousands of other Rangers that come out
just fine they have families they're
able to be compassionate and there's
nothing wrong with you know yours not
cut out for that that's just simple as
that yeah it's like it's like you know
like people who do mixed martial arts at
the highest level right the type of
training that they go through is not the
same type of training that people do at
the gym yeah you know so if a mixed
martial artist comes out he goes dude
you know what my coach made me do
he made why not this hill with a bunch
of weights I got beat up punched in the
face I for me I'm not that doesn't gain
sympathy for me I'm like no you're a
[ __ ] elite athlete like I expect that
I don't feel bad for you like you're two
years you're not incarcerated if you
sign up for planet fitness and they said
they made you
welcome to Planet Fitness but if you're
trying to train for like the heavyweight
world title didn't like I think you
should do more of that actually say for
example you're going through the Ranger
training and then you seriously do reach
your breaking point you can't do it you
can quit anytime too by the way you just
go back to being a normal army person
but then he Ortiz was broken after basic
training what I'm getting from this is
he's kind of blaming that type of
programming to make him so desensitized
to where he's okay with doing crime now
and being shitty to human beings yeah
that's when the story goes into it
that's a deeper mental problem that's
his problem
I mean to me it's kind of like if that
was the truth then everyone that is a
Navy SEAL Army Ranger whatever
specialized that anymore is a psychopath
that can kill every civilian you know
like the Ranger School might have added
to it but it there it was something deep
rooted in him yeah time it's and he
can't solely blame that on Ranger school
[Music]
you